Okay, so let's get stuck in to video
number nine, our next leading indicator,
so our fifth leading indicator, the
University of Michigan Consumer Sentiment
Index, or the UMCSI.
So yes, we are going to be having a look
now at consumers and a survey in the
consumer sector of the economy.
So, recap of leading indicators covered so
far. We've got our government bond markets
leading indicators, real interest rates
and the yield curve.
We've got our corporate bond markets
leading indicators, our investment grade
with high yield or junk spreads over the
10-year.
We've got our M2 money supply accessory.
We've got our stock market volatility, the
VIX, the S&P 500 VIX from the IPLT video
series, and we've got our surveys.
And so far, we have covered the ISM
Manufacturing Report on Business, and
we've covered the ISM Non-Manufacturing
Report on Business.
Now, we are going to add in the US
consumer by looking at the University of
Michigan Consumer Sentiment Index.
So what exactly is the UMCSI? What is it?
Well, it's a monthly survey that gauges
the level of consumer sentiment in the US
economy.
So, sentiment as to whether consumers as a
whole in the US economy are either bullish
or bearish on their future.
So, if consumer sentiment is high, so
consumers in the US are bullish on their
future, consumers are likely to be
spending more in the future, causing the
economy to expand.
So there's more consumption and
potentially less saving.
If consumer sentiment is low, so bearish
on the future, so consumers in the US are
looking at their future, and they're
bearish on their consumer sentiment for
the future.
So, what's going to happen? Consumers will
likely spend less in the future, causing
the economy to contract.
So we get less consumption and people
tightening their belts and saving more.
Now, the consumer, we calculate the size
of the consumer in the US in terms of the
amount of consumer spending that takes
place in the economy.
And consumer spending makes up 67% of the
US economy.
And if you recall, there's not many
entities that make up an economy.
It's just businesses, consumers, and
government.
And businesses and consumers are in the
private sector, and government is in the
public sector.
So if we're looking at consumer spending
making up 67% of the economy, the
remainder is business and government
spending.
So the consumer, US consumer spending
makes up the majority of spending of those
entities in the United States.
So it obviously stands to reason that as
traders and portfolio managers, gauging
consumer sentiment in the United States is
extremely important as a leading indicator
to the future of the economy, so GDP
growth.
Now, before we get into the details of the
UMCSI, it's probably prudent at this stage
to have a quick lesson on some economic
theory to understand the dynamics of
consumers.
So what we're going to have a look at
first is something called the paradox of
thrift, which was popularized by the
famous economist John Maynard Keynes.
And it's based on the notion, which we
outlined briefly on the previous slide,
whereby individuals seek to cut their
consumption during periods of economic
contraction and increase their savings.
So tightening their belt overall, which in
turn will lead to further contraction.
So think about this, when there's an
economic downturn, if all that consumers
are reading in the media are headlines
like, get ready for the recession, what's
their natural tendency going to be?
Their natural tendency is going to be to
cut consumption, to save and hoard cash
and resources.
And what does that lead to in the future?
Well, it causes a steeper and faster
contraction in the economy, in GDP, so GDP
growth, because of the sudden fall in
consumer demand, which leads to a longer
and deeper period of contraction.
So the paradox occurs because the only way
really for an economy to get itself out of
contraction is to obviously expand.
And the only way to expand is to actually
spend.
So the spending causes an increase in
aggregate demand, which generates price
inflation and then GDP growth.
However, when individual consumers expect
worse economic conditions in the future,
their sentiment of the future is negative.
And instead of doing what's required,
which is to spend in order to expand, what
do they do in reality?
They do the opposite and they save and
they cut consumer spending.
And collectively, if we take all consumers
in an economy, if they're all making this
decision at an individual level, and then
we look at all consumers in the economy,
by not spending collectively, consumers
are essentially causing their own economic
situation or living standards to be even
worse in the future.
So this is the paradox of thrift.
So being thrifty in an economic downturn,
because all the consumers, it's in their
best interests for the economy to expand.
However, their actions are the opposite of
what's good for them.
Now, if we think of the paradox of thrift
in reverse, well, it's a little
far-fetched to say that it's in the best
interests when an economy is expanding
that consumers would want.
So it's in their best interests, they
would want an economy to contract.
So think about it.
If an economy is expanding for a long
period of time, why would consumers want
the economy to contract?
It's not in their best interest.
So when we look at the paradox of thrift
in reverse, there's an issue here, because
as far as consumers and long-term
investors in the stock market are
concerned, let's ask ourselves this
question.
Is it bad to always be expanding and
benefiting from higher living standards?
Well, of course not.
Basically, for living standards and your
own individual economic condition as a
consumer, contraction is bad and expansion
is good.
So the behavior of consumers in times of
thrift, so during times of contraction, is
not consistent with consumer behavior in
times of expansion during, for lack of a
better word, during times of extravagance.
So if we apply the same logic to an
economy that's expanding a lot for a long
period of time, if we wanted to make them
consistent, we would be stating that
consumers should be spending less and
saving more in order to better their own
living standards or economic situation.
But this would be counterintuitive,
because if all consumers did this, it
would cause them to all have worse living
standards.
Why?
Because overall economic growth in the
economy would go down, and that's bad for
everybody, everybody's living standards
and economic situation individually.
So when consumer sentiment is high, and
we're in times of extravagance, it can be
argued that consumers are actually
behaving rationally.
So they are spending more and more and
continually causing their own living
standards or economic situation to get
better and better.
And when consumer sentiment is low, it can
obviously be argued that consumers are
behaving irrationally.
So they are cautious, they are hoarding,
they are saving, and what ends up
happening?
They cause their own living standards or
economic situation to get worse and worse.
And what they should be doing is spending.
So this is an interesting dynamic of
consumer behavior to understand as we lead
in to doing work on the University of
Michigan Consumer Sentiment Index.
It's just good background information in
terms of economic understanding of how
consumers behave.
We will read into our numbers in a lot
better understanding if we understand how
consumers behave in periods of thrift or
contraction and periods of expansion and
extravagance.
Now, something else to understand when
we're thinking about consumers, it's not a
consumer behavior or, if you like,
consumer psychology variable or factor to
consider.
This is a capacity issue.
We do have finite resources and consumers
have finite parameters.
One limiting factor is just the purchase
of products, okay?
A consumer can only have, at any one time,
so many cars, washing machines,
refrigerators, handheld devices, phones,
et cetera, et cetera.
This is a finite constraint on consumers.
So when we think about that in terms of
extravagance, there is a cycle to this,
okay?
There is a cycle where consumers get
constrained and then there's nothing left
to consume.
Logically and in theory, that can be the
case.
Another limiting factor and probably much
more important from a trader's and
portfolio manager's perspective is that
consumers in their behaviors,
so consumer spending and savings rates,
are also a function of the money supply
and the price of money, so real interest
rates,
both of which can be decreased and
increased by the Fed when they're
utilizing conventional and unconventional
means to hit their dual mandate.
So this is a real, everyday parameter
that's finite in the economy.
Consumer spending has peaks and troughs
like business activity.
So when we looked at the ISM and the NMI,
they move in tandem and literally taking
together.
So when we take together consumer spending
and business activity, they make up the
business cycle.
So if you recall from video four, when we
looked at real interest rates in the yield
curve, you may want to go back and have a
look at this slide.
I've put it on the screen there for you to
remind you there's cycles to this based on
interest rates, okay, based on real rates
and the money supply.
Money becomes cheap and money becomes
expensive and consumer spending responds
to this parameter and so do businesses.
Businesses, so businesses and consumers,
so businesses and consumers expand and
contract together.
Business investment and consumer spending
patterns or behaviors are to a large
extent a function of real rates and the
money supply.
So if you recall, just looking at the
screenshot of the slide from video four
there, when money becomes cheap,
governments, companies and individuals, so
consumers, borrow more of it.
We get higher growth prospects,
consumption.
So from consumers, we get higher
consumption and investment from
businesses.
How does that lead into the equity markets
where we get higher equity valuation and
earnings from companies.
So we get higher corporate earnings and
higher equity market valuation.
And then we come to the end of the cycle
and then we come to the end of the cycle
and money becomes more expensive.
And what happens then, governments,
companies and individuals, or are less, we
get lower growth prospects or perhaps
contraction, we get less consumption and
investment, we get lower equity valuation
and earnings.
And then we start the cycle again, money
starts to become cheap.
So this is how consumers fit in to the
overall picture.
Businesses and consumers expand and
contract together.
And quarterly and annual gross domestic
product numbers, so the GDP prints, lag
the S&P 500 price and earnings.
Businesses and earnings and valuation,
which are a function of consumer spending
patterns and behaviours and business
investment.
So when we're considering consumers in the
economy, we not only have to understand
consumer behaviour and consumer
psychology, if you like, with the paradox
of thrift.
So the opposite doesn't line up, doesn't
make logical sense.
We also have to consider how everything is
linked together and how consumers face a
finite set of variables or parameters.
So real interest rates and the money
supply.
So we don't just look at consumers in
absolute terms.
We have to consider consumer behaviour in
the context of everything else that is
happening in the economy.
Therefore, from a trader and portfolio
manager perspective, everything that's
happening with the rest of our leading
indicators,
especially what's happening in the money
markets and with businesses.
So both in the manufacturing and services,
so non-manufacturing sectors of the
economy.
Now, there are critics of the paradox of
thrift.
Quick reminder of what we've laid out so
far in terms of consumer behaviour, in
terms of rational behaviour, where there's
no paradox.
This is during periods of expansion, so
periods of extravagance.
If consumer sentiment is high, so they are
bullish on the future, consumers will
spend more in the future, causing the
economy to expand more.
So in this period, what's the consumer
behaving like?
There's more consumption, less savings, so
possibly not getting richer.
But during these periods of expansion,
they are associated with higher innovation
in the economy, more products and higher
living standards.
So consumers are buying more products to
improve their living standards.
What about the paradox of thrift?
So the irrational behaviour.
Well, if consumer sentiment is low, so
they're bearish on the future, consumers
spend less in the future.
This causes the economy to contract.
So less consumption and more savings.
So they're definitely not getting richer
during this time.
There's less innovation.
They're consuming less products and their
living standards are staying the same or
perhaps getting worse.
Now, we looked on the previous slide at
the finite dynamics, the limiting factors
that affect consumer behaviour.
And how does this all linked together?
Well, through the economic cycle,
supposedly, during times of extravagance,
interest rates will go higher.
Real interest rates will go higher.
And consumers are supposed to, in theory,
respond in their behaviour by increasing
their savings rate and decreasing their
consumption.
But in reality, that doesn't happen.
Periods of extravagance tend to last a lot
longer than expected.
And consumers tend to consume even more.
And when consumers do this, there's
actually no paradox.
This is actually rational behaviour
because continued economic growth is just
good for everybody.
It's better for everybody's living
standards.
And what happens in periods of
contraction?
Well, we have interest rates falling.
So lower real rates.
And how do consumers respond to that?
Well, they respond irrationally.
They respond paradoxically via the
mechanism of the economic theory of the
paradox of thrift.
This occurs by people saving more as
interest rates are falling and consuming
less as well at the same time.
So the paradox is, is that at this part of
the cycle, consumers should be spending
their way out of the contraction.
But they are not.
They are tightening their belts.
They are hoarding cash, hoarding resources
and consuming less.
So the critics of Keynes' theory of the
paradox of thrift, they criticise it on
the grounds that an increase in savings
from consumers
allows banks to lend more money via an
increase in bank reserves through the
fractional reserve banking system.
So the idea is that as long as the money
supply is constant, the business cycle
should be self-correcting and shouldn't
require any intervention in the market
because market interest rates should go
down and lead to a natural increase in
lending from the banks and therefore
spending from consumers at some point.
Now, this is all good in theory to say
that the economy will be self-correcting.
If we think about this, then the opposite
must hold true in theory.
If we have constant money supply growth
when savings rates are lower and
consumption is high during expansionary
periods,
so in those times of extravagance, then
naturally market interest rates should go
higher or will go higher.
And then that will naturally lead to a
decrease in lending and therefore consumer
spending.
Unfortunately, guys, the world really
isn't that simple.
It's messy and there's no ultimate truth
or rule book as to what should be
occurring or what happens at any one time
or in any particular business cycle.
It's obviously can be different every
time.
But from a trader's and portfolio
manager's perspective, if we're going to
understand consumer sentiment in the US
and use it as a leading indicator,
we have to understand these dynamics of
consumers.
We have to understand the business cycle
that is connected, that consumer behavior
is connected to the other parameters of
the economy.
So businesses, for example, and real
interest rates and the money supply.
We have to understand that.
So whenever we look at the consumer
sentiment index in the United States, we
have to understand the consumer behavior
in the context of all other indicators and
what else is going on in the economy.
We also have to understand that there
could be long periods of irrational
consumer behavior and understand why that
is happening.
It's probably occurring due to the paradox
of thrift.
We also have to understand that there
could be very short periods of irrational
behavior.
Again, paradox of thrift.
We have to understand that something could
occur that makes consumers begin spending
again in times of economic contraction.
We also have to understand the dynamic of
the rational behavior that in periods of
expansion that could be extremely long
times of rational behavior from consumers
where they're spending a lot longer than
people expect.
So we have to take all of this into
context, guys.
We have to understand consumer behavior
and consumer psychology.
And we have to understand the limiting
factors on consumers.
And from a trader's and portfolio
manager's perspective, understand the
other parameters in the economy and how
consumers are linked to the other areas of
the economy and their consumer behavior
and how it's all linked together.
So this way, in the future, when we pull
up the University of Michigan Consumer
Sentiment Index and we see the number and
we look at the chart and we look at where
we've come from and where we are now and
where we might be going, we get a much
better understanding when we think of the
U.S. consumer and U.S. consumer sentiment
in the context of how consumers behave.
And how it fits in to the rest of the
economy and the dynamics that are playing
out.
Because at any one time, things will be
different relative to another time in the
business cycle or in previous business
cycles.
So we have to understand the context and
keep asking ourselves the questions.
Why are consumers behaving in this way?
What does it mean in terms of the business
cycle?
What does it mean in terms of the context
of real interest rates and the money
supply and money market dynamics?
What does it mean in the context of
current Fed policy?
And we're going to get a much clearer
picture if we ask ourselves those
questions at any one moment in time.
So the U.S. Consumer Sentiment Index
itself, the UMCSI, the University of
Michigan Consumer Sentiment Index, as a
trader or portfolio manager, how do we
actually use it?
Well, what we do know is that consumer
sentiment historically does have peaks and
troughs, its cycles.
And when we use it in conjunction with
other macroeconomic indicators, we can
work out at any one given time what is
going on with the U.S. consumer and the
economy.
And therefore, we have a great indicator
for predicting GDP growth and for calling
the direction of the S&P 500 or the U.S.
stock market and likely stock market
returns and Fed policy.
And this, like our other leading
indicators that we've looked at so far,
dictates to us the likely directional bias
that we're going to have.
So a long bias, bullish, a short bias,
bearish or a neutral bias.
So agnostic bias in our portfolios as
traders.
Now, consumer spending is 67% of the U.S.
economy, as we mentioned previously.
And it is historically highly predictive
of GDP growth in the future.
It's also very predictive of stock market
direction and potential stock market
returns and likely Fed policy.
So guys, let's have a look now at the
detail of the UMCSI.
Let's have a look at the survey design.
So the way the survey is put together each
month.
Basically, the University of Michigan
Consumer Research Center conducts a
telephone survey asking 500, yes, only 500
consumers a series of questions on their
personal finances and their opinions on
business conditions.
So the way it's broken up, the way it's
split up, it's split into two component
areas that have an equal 50% weighting
given to each area.
So we have the aggregate consumer
sentiment index, which is the ICS.
And that is made up of two areas with an
equal 50% weighting.
That's the index of current conditions,
the ICC, and the index of consumer
expectations, the ICE.
Now, this is what it looks like on the
surface level.
But as always, as traders and portfolio
managers, we do have to dig a little
deeper to try and find out which are the
most useful areas for us in predicting
future GDP growth and stock market
direction.
So let's have a look at how this is broken
down properly.
We mentioned the two areas, the current
conditions index and the consumer
expectations index, making up the index
overall, the aggregate index of consumer
sentiment.
And the way that's split up, we have the
five questions and current conditions is
questions number one and five.
And the expectations index.
So for consumer expectations, that relates
to questions two, three, and four.
So let's first have a look at current
conditions.
So one and five.
Firstly, the 500 consumers are asked, we
are interested in how people are getting
along financially these days.
Would you say that you and your family are
better off or worse off financially than
you were a year ago?
That's the first question.
Question number five.
About the big things people buy for their
homes, such as furniture, a refrigerator,
stove, television, and things like that.
Generally speaking, do you think now is a
good or bad time for people to buy major
household items?
So these are the two questions that make
up the current conditions index.
They're basically asking the consumers,
are you better off or worse off
financially than a year ago?
And are you going to be spending money on
major household items?
So they are basically being surveyed or
tested, if you like, on their view of
their current financial situation, which
obviously measures current sentiment.
Now let's have a look at expectations.
So looking into the future.
So we're looking at questions two, three,
and four.
So question two.
Looking ahead.
Do you think that a year from now, you and
your family will be better off financially
or worse off or just about the same as
now?
Question three.
Turning to business conditions in the
country as a whole.
Do you think that during the next 12
months we'll have good times financially
or bad times or what?
Question four.
Looking ahead.
Which would you say is more likely?
That in the country as a whole we'll have
continuous good times during the next five
years or so?
Or that we will have periods of widespread
unemployment or depression or what?
So it's pretty obvious here what consumers
are being surveyed on, what they're being
tested on, is their expectations of the
future if they are bullish, bearish or
neutral of their own consumer
expectations, their own consumer sentiment
of the future.
Now, in terms of the data, you can go to
the downloads area and you can look at the
UMCSI file where we have the entire
history data set of the University of
Michigan Consumer Sentiment Index and the
components, the current conditions and the
expectations data.
And what you'll also see is changes in the
component indexes.
So with current conditions and
expectations, the changes on a month by
month basis in terms of points.
And you'll also see that for the aggregate
index as well.
So you'll find as well in the spreadsheets
that we've taken the data and created a
whole bunch of visuals.
So charts from the data.
If we look here, the main one is the
headline aggregate UMCSI with all data
going back to 1978.
So the visual is there in the downloads
area.
And next one, you'll see that we have the
all time aggregate index of the UMCSI with
the changes month on month on the chart as
well.
We also do this for both the current
conditions and expectations index.
So you'll see that the same visuals and
same analysis for the all time series and
for the changes month on month are there
for both the current conditions and the
expectations index as well.
Now, as we've done in our previous videos
where we've looked at certain times in the
past to look at how certain leading
indicators were behaving at certain
periods of time.
We can do that obviously as well for the
UMCSI.
So if we look at the period August 18 to
August 19, that was the period that we've
looked at in previous videos.
We can see at the headline level of the
UMCSI that we didn't really get a big drop
in consumer sentiment at the aggregate
level during that time.
So if we look at the data from August 18
to August 19, you can see the move 96.2
down to 89.8, but in July 19, the
aggregate index was 98.4.
So there's only really two moves during
that period at the aggregate level where
the index fell by a decent amount of
points.
That's January 19 and August 19.
But we can look at the component parts and
see what that's driven by.
If we look at the current conditions
index, the current conditions index stays
above 100 the entire time and is extremely
strong.
Okay.
But the expectations index is actually
what's driving the aggregate fall.
So we can see in January 19, a fall down
in expectations.
That was a move in conjunction with
current conditions.
But you can see the moves down overall,
and the big move down in August 19 from
expectations of 10.6 points.
So in August 19, the expectations index is
79.9, and the current conditions index is
105.3, leaving the aggregate index at
89.8.
So what's interesting during this period
is that the aggregate level, so at the
aggregate index, the way we would read
this is that there wasn't a consumer
recession, for want of a better word,
during this period, August 18 to August
19.
However, there was a very big concern over
consumer expectations.
There was no current concern, i.e. what
consumers were currently experiencing in
the economy in terms of their sentiment.
But their expectations of the future were
dwindling.
And when we put this in a bigger context,
when we think about previous videos in the
video series, and when we looked at this
period, if you recall, we determined that
during this period, it was essentially
down to a manufacturing slowdown, not a
services slowdown.
And if we put this into context now, we
can see that there was no consumer
slowdown at the aggregate level, and the
current conditions of consumer sentiment.
It was their expectation of the future.
The consumer was getting tired in the US
in 2019.
And they were signaling that they were
going to spend less via their own consumer
sentiment and expectations in the future.
So this is pretty interesting because we
know that the Fed cut rates in July,
September and October.
So this is how you can see it all starts
to link together.
And if we look further down in the data,
when we look at the second half of 2019,
we can see the aggregate level by the end
of the year pretty much gets back up to
100.
In December 2019, we're looking at a
reading of 99.3.
And you can see a decent recovery in
expectations and definitely a strong
recovery in current conditions.
If we look further into the COVID era, so
if we look into the first half of 2020, we
can see a total collapse of expectations
in the spring of 2020,
where we go from above 90 at the beginning
of 2020.
And we look at the data.
A few months later, we can see when the
COVID lows go in, which is March 2020.
We can see expectations of 79.7.
And we can see in May 2020, expectations
hitting a low of 65.9.
And the expectations index really
struggled to get moving for the rest of
2020.
Also, the current conditions index really
struggled as well for most of 2020 after
getting hit due to the COVID economic
shutdown.
And, you know, just bear in mind, the Fed
actions came in March, April, May, June.
And the effect that it had on consumers
wasn't actually as big as expected.
And it took a long time for consumers to
start to come back.
What you're actually seeing there, when we
look at the 2019 period, and we look at it
compared to the 2020 COVID economic
lockdown period,
you're looking now at the period of
extended extravagance versus the period of
the paradox of thrift.
We can also have a look at the global
financial crisis.
During that time, what was going on with
consumers?
Well, the UMCSI has peaks and drops like
other leading indicators.
And we had peak conditions for consumers.
You'll see that in the data in the
spreadsheet in January 2007, with a
reading at the aggregate level of 96.9.
And we had a consumer trough in the global
financial crisis of 56.3 in February 2009.
So you can see that's a full two years
from Jan 07, where we had a gradual
decline from peak throughout 2007,
and then through 2008 to February 2009,
where we had the trough.
So that's a full two years.
That's obviously a pretty long period of
time for consumption to be declining.
So it gives you a good perspective and
understanding of how the consumer behaves
sometimes in the US.
Coming out of the consumer trough as well,
you can see if we look on the right hand
side,
we want to know here, how long did it take
for the US consumer to actually recover?
Well, we know that the Fed was obviously
very, very active during that time.
They had quantitative easing programmes in
place.
They also had conventional means.
So they lowered interest rates extremely
aggressively during the financial crisis.
But coming out of the financial crisis,
there was non-conventional monetary policy
of quantitative easing.
So they'd already had one quantitative
easing programme.
And they implemented the second one, which
didn't actually finish until June 29th,
2012.
And when we look at the US consumer data,
the Fed's huge, unprecedented actions at
that time,
it took a long time for those actions to
actually have an effect on the US consumer
and the US consumer recovery.
The US consumer didn't really recover
until 2012.
So if you look at the data there, you can
see, for example, the data going back into
the 70s consistently in the first half of
2012.
But not getting above 80 until the second
half of 2012.
So as you can see, this is a very long
period of time where the UMCSI at an
aggregate level peaked in January 2007.
And then even after the massive,
unprecedented Fed policy and actions
during and out of the financial crisis,
the consumer only really tepidly recovered
by the second half of 2012.
So five years and the US consumer didn't
even get back to the level where it was in
January 2007,
even by the second half of 2012, which
when you think about it is obviously a
very long time.
And what you're experiencing here again is
the, if you like, irrational behavior of
consumers with the paradox of thrift.
If everybody went out and started spending
their way out of this crisis, it might
have been over a lot quicker.
And the Fed may have needed to take less
action throughout the following decade.
But you can see what their behavior was
coming out of the global financial crisis.
They were obviously tightening their belts
and very, very cautious about their
spending.
And nowhere near as extravagant with their
spending coming out of the global
financial crisis as they were going into
it.
So you can see by looking at the data,
these periods of thrift can last a very
long time.
And also, if you look at periods of
extravagance, periods of expansion, those
periods can last a lot longer than
expected as well.
But how do we actually use the UMCSI as
traders and portfolio managers?
Well, unlike our business indicators, the
ISM Manufacturing Index and the Non
Manufacturing Index, the UMCSI doesn't
have a defined level that signifies future
expansion and contraction in the US
economy.
So you'll notice on our charts, what we've
done is we put a simple trend line average
of the aggregate UMCSI.
And we correlated this with long-term US
GDP growth.
So the way we use it as traders and
portfolio managers is we look at the UMCSI
as a kind of zonal guide for general
levels of economic growth and as a
directional guide in conjunction with the
expectations index.
So we look at the level of the UMCSI as a
guide to basically help us predict the
direction and a certain level of GDP
growth around certain levels or certain
gates.
So if at any one time we're looking at the
UMCSI and we see multiple readings above
80, well, we know that we have bullish
consumers above this level.
We should be expecting, based on
historical data, that annualized GDP
growth is going to be 2% or higher.
If we have readings between 70 and 80, we
kind of have, based on historical
sentiment, benign consumers.
We should expect, when we have readings
between 70 and 80, for annualized GDP
growth to be somewhere between 0% and 2%.
And if we have readings between 55 and 70,
based on historical data, we have bearish
consumers.
We should be expecting annualized GDP
growth to be in a very wide range of
negative 5% to plus 1%, but more likely to
be 0 to negative.
Now, as mentioned previously, the UMCSI,
like other leading indicators, does have
peaks and troughs.
And essentially, peaks are where the
consumer in the US is at capacity.
And based on historical probability,
sentiment at some point is more likely to
fall.
However, when we're looking at it at a
certain period in time, at any one moment
in time, we can't say exactly how long
these conditions will continue.
Because every cycle is different, because
every cycle is different, and we have to
consider the other factors.
So we have to consider the other factors
that we looked at earlier, of consumer
behavior and psychology, and also the
other leading indicators, especially the
money market dynamics.
But the troughs are basically where
consumers in the US have gotten, via the
paradox of thrift, too bearish and
miserable.
And they now have capacity for spending,
so they can go out and begin buying
discretionary items instead of just
necessities.
But again, like the peaks, every cycle is
different, and we can't say exactly how
long this period of bearish consumer
sentiment or thriftiness is going to last.
And again, we have to use it in
conjunction with everything else that's
going on in the other leading indicators
at any one moment in time.
But let's have a look at the chart of the
data where we compare the UM-CSI aggregate
versus real GDP growth.
So we have the UM-CSI on the right-hand
side, and we have real GDP growth on the
left-hand side.
The blue line on the chart is the UM-CSI
reading.
The green line, the green lines are the
bars for the level of GDP growth that's
reported quarterly.
And the red line is a long-term average
growth rate of US annualized GDP.
So you can see when we look at moments in
history where we've had multiple readings
above the 80 level, this is generally
correlated with GDP growth of 2% or above.
And then when we have multiple readings
between 70 and 80, we're looking at benign
consumers.
And this generally correlates anything
between 0% and 2%.
And then if we have multiple readings
between 55 and 70, we tend to get growth
between minus 5% and 1%.
So this is looking back across the whole
data set and looking at a zonal approach
to the UM-CSI versus predicting direction
and size of GDP growth.
Now, something we've also done in the
downloads area is look at the UM-CSI
versus S&P 500 direction and year-on-year
percentage returns.
And what you can see by looking at the
data set and looking at this visually,
what you can see is that when we have
multiple readings throughout the data set
above 80, this is generally very obviously
associated with positive direction in the
stock market and very good percentage
returns annually in the S&P 500.
In our next zone, when we look at the 70
to 80 level, we still get when you look
through the data set, when we have benign
consumers, positive stock market returns.
So in terms of direction, positive and
decent to good returns on a year-on-year
basis in the stock market, where the
problems occur for the stock market is
when we have multiple readings below 70.
We look at the 70 across the data set
across the data set that is generally
associated with either very weak stock
market positive returns, flat or negative
to very negative returns on a year-on-year
basis for the S&P 500.
So when we look at the 70.
So when we think about this in terms of a
zonal approach and think about GDP
direction, the percentage of GDP growth
and also the direction of the S&P 500 and
the percentage return in the S&P 500, when
we're using the UM-CSI and looking at it
as a zonal approach,
when we're using the S&P 500, when we're
using the S&P 500, we're using the S&P 500
and looking at it as a zonal approach.
When we're using the S&P 500, when we're
using the S&P 500, when we're using the
S&P 500, when we're using the S&P 500,
we're using the S&P 500.
We're using the S&P 500.
We're using S&P 500.
S&P 500.
We've also added in a chart where you can
look at the UM-CSI aggregate in blue here
and have
a look at the expectations and current
conditions index all on the same chart.
So go into the spreadsheet and have a look
at all of the data and work on the data
and the charts
to understand the nuts and bolts of the US
consumer.
Now there are other things that when we're
looking at the US consumer, we have to be
aware of in terms of things in the bigger
picture just to fill everything in.
At any one moment in time, it's just good
to be aware of these things that we're
going to look at now.
Because it tells us for consumers in the
United States, the capacity of the
consumer.
So if you recall from the causality of
consumer behavior and spending patterns
from earlier slides,
we looked at consumer spending and savings
rates being a function of real interest
rates and the money supply,
which are obviously both manipulated and
managed by the Federal Reserve.
the Fed is obviously very active in
managing real interest rates and the money
supply.
And this affects the way consumers behave,
the way they spend and the way they save.
And there's certain statistics we can look
at in the US economy to get an
appreciation and understanding in the
bigger picture of consumer capacity.
So something we would look at on a regular
basis every quarter to understand the
consumer capacity is US household debt to
GDP.
So the level of household debt to gross
domestic product expressed in percentage
terms.
So what is household debt?
Well, it's made up of mortgages, consumer
loans, credit card balances and auto
finance.
And if you look at the chart on the left
hand side, our data from trading economics
is going back to the 1950s.
And you can obviously see a steady rise in
the level of household debt as a
percentage of GDP all the way up to
present day.
And obviously it peaked around the mid
2000s before the financial crisis.
And where we are now at the time of
recording is essentially, if you look at
the right hand side for a zoomed in
picture, 76% of GDP.
So household debt is 76% of GDP in the
United States at the time of recording.
So why would we look at this on a regular
basis?
Well, we just want to get an appreciation
and understanding as to whether there's
actually capacity for consumers to grow or
be bullish in the future.
So being at 76% and coming down from a
level of almost close to 100% versus GDP,
there's obviously slack and capacity in
the economy.
There's no capacity for this to occur.
So there's enough capacity for an
increased debt load relative to GDP to
occur.
But obviously, a lot depends on interest
rates and the cost of servicing any
outstanding debt in the economy.
Something else we would look at on a
regular basis to understand capacity
issues is US household debt service
payments as a percentage of disposable
personal income.
And if you look at the chart coming from
1980 up until time of recording, you can
see obviously the percentage of US
household debt service payments versus
disposable personal income.
It's been up and down for that entire
period.
And typically before 2010, it was between
10% and 13%.
But you can see given the moves that we've
had in interest rates over the last decade
from the time of recording over the last
decade, you can see that this percentage
of household debt service payments
relative to personal income has been
dropping by quite a lot.
So what does that mean?
Well, servicing the debt relative to
income has become a lot cheaper for
households in the United States.
So it means that there's obviously
capacity to occur in terms of servicing
debt and the total debt load.
So that gives consumers room to be
bullish.
Something else we would look at on a
quarterly basis is a household and
non-profit organization, one to four
family residential mortgage liability.
And we look at the total debt load here on
those mortgages.
And if you look at the left hand side, in
billions of dollars, you can see it's
above the 10,000 billion mark, which is 10
trillion.
Does that mean there's no capacity left?
Of course not.
This is just a dollar figure.
So of course, more capacity can occur.
But you can see the general trend since
the 70s has been on a big rise.
We peaked in the financial crisis.
And it looks like the one to four family
residential mortgage liability is growing
above the global financial crisis level.
So again, does this mean there's a
capacity issue if this thing goes up a lot
higher?
Not necessarily, as mentioned before on
the previous slide, it's the level of
interest that is important here as well.
So it's the size of the debt load and the
cost that households incur relative to
their personal income in servicing that
debt load.
So we keep an eye on these things on a
quarterly basis and we just take note of
them and what it might mean for consumer
capacity in terms of household debt and
the cost of servicing that debt.
And we put it into context with our other
leading indicators and we fill in the
bigger picture and try to understand at
any one moment in time what's going on in
the economy.
And of course, if you look at the chart
here and compare it to the household debt
charts on the previous slides and what
have we got here, we've got the 10 year
yield adjusted for CPI.
So adjusted for inflation.
So we've got the real 10 year yield since
1980.
And this obviously, if you look at the
modern context, gives you an idea of Fed
policy and what they're trying to achieve
here and think about it in the context of
the previous slides and household debt.
So real interest rates have been coming
down over the last 40 years and coming
down from a level of around 8% to modern
day as negative.
Yes, of course, there's a big question
here in that over the bigger picture.
Is it necessary for this to happen because
the debt load is so high that the Fed has
to be in the market creating conditions of
zero to negative real rates in order for
households to service that debt.
And the big question is their capacity for
further debt to be added to the US
economy.
Well, we looked at the previous slides and
it can be argued both ways, but we just
need to keep an eye on these numbers on a
quarterly basis.
So the household debt numbers and, of
course, real rates, we need to be keeping
an eye on them all the time.
And thinking about what that means in the
context of consumer capacity, consumer
behavior and consumer psychology and also
what the UMCSI is telling us.
So let's have a summary of the University
of Michigan Consumer Sentiment Index.
So we know that consumer spending is
dominant.
It makes up 67% of all spending in the
United States.
So it's obviously very important for us to
be on top of this as traders and portfolio
managers.
How consumers feel about their current, so
coincident, and expected future income
affects GDP growth, which is lagging.
So it is a leading indicator.
And not just that, the UMCSI is a powerful
leading indicator of US GDP growth and S&P
500 direction and potential returns.
So it's vitally important to us as
professional traders, our portfolio
managers for our portfolio buyers.
Because consumer spending makes up such a
large part of all spending in the US, the
US consumer drives US GDP growth and
global GDP growth and stock market returns
in the US and the rest of the world.
How do we use it as professional traders?
Well, we use it as a guide in conjunction
with money market indicators and our other
leading indicators to predict trends and
turning points in the business cycle and
therefore getting our portfolio
directional bias.
So net long or short or even neutral
portfolio bias.
And remember, there is no defined levels
like the business activity indices, like
the ISM manufacturing and
non-manufacturing indices, where we have
the 50 level signifying above 50 expansion
and below 50 contraction.
The UMCSI doesn't have that.
We have to use it as a zonal guide and
correlate it with GDP growth in those
zones and stock market direction and
returns to get a rough guide of what to
expect.
And we also have to be very careful in our
understanding of consumer behavior and
psychology when looking at consumer
sentiment.
So, periods of thrift, because of the
paradox of thrift, can occur in small
windows of time, but they can also occur
in very long windows of time as well.
And we shouldn't be surprised when that
happens.
Additionally, on the flip side, periods of
extravagance can occur for a much longer
period of time as well.
So, we have to be aware of that when we're
thinking about peaks and troughs and also
the effect the UMCSI has on GDP growth
going forward.
But because, as well, the UMCSI in
measuring consumer sentiment and because
it's so important in terms of consumer
spending driving the economy, of course,
the Fed is looking at it as well.
So, in the back of our minds always, at
any one point in time, when we're asking
ourselves, what does all this mean?
We have to ask ourselves the question as
well, is the Fed looking at this and is
the Fed likely to engage in some sort of
policy response?
So, by using the UMCSI in conjunction with
our money market leading indicators and
our other macroeconomic indicators, we're
going to have a very good understanding of
the US economy, money flows and potential
Fed policy.
So, guys, we've now looked at, in terms of
surveys, we've looked at businesses, so
the ISM manufacturing and the ISM
non-manufacturing.
And we've also looked at, now, consumers.
In the next video, we're going to be
looking at the US construction industry.
But first, before we do that, let's go
back to the desk for a brief chat.
Okay, so that was the US consumer and the
main consumer survey in the United States,
the University of Michigan Consumer
Sentiment Index, the UMCSI.
You can now see that we're starting to get
to a stage in the video series where we're
building a very comprehensive
macroeconomic dashboard.
So, we've got our money market indicators
and we're building up our surveys.
And as you saw in that video with the US
consumer, we have to understand how
consumers themselves actually think and
operate.
So, this actually, in the video, was a
quick lesson in economic theory that you
would have gotten if you were actually
completing, at university, an economics
degree.
Now, with our historic examples, you can
see now, as well, that when we actually
marry up our surveys together, and when we
look at them in the context of the money
markets, you can get a very good picture
of how the US economy is doing at any one
moment in time.
And I would encourage you, all of you, to
do this.
Look at business cycle history and
understand what is going on during those
periods of booms and busts.
So, periods of business cycle history in
the US economy.
Ultimately, what we're always trying to do
here as traders is determine stock market
direction and hence our portfolio bias.
If you study former business cycles, so
business cycle history, and you learn how
to interpret numbers during those times,
and in the context of the economy at that
moment in time, what happens?
You just get better at interpretation for
the future.
So, you get better at calling your
portfolio bias.
OK. So, make sure you are on top of the
UMCSI every month.
Use the downloadable spreadsheets that are
downloadable in the downloads area next to
the video.
Use those spreadsheets for all of your
leading indicators and update them
regularly.
If you do this, you're going to have a
very good idea of what's going on and
become very good at interpreting the
numbers.
You'll become competent at calling stock
market direction and portfolio direction.
OK. So, we're going to move on to our next
leading indicator.
We're going to move on to building
permits.
Now, this is a very interesting leading
indicator because it just tells us so much
about what's happening in many different
parts of the economy.
And as with every macro indicator that we
go through, we're going to go through an
explanation of how it works, obviously.
But we're also going to refer to business
cycle history and examples of business
cycle history.
And we're going to use examples of stocks
and sectors as well.
So, we'll do this in building permits.
Enjoy the video, and I'll see you a bit
later on in the video series.